BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST STORIES O
THE LAST DECADE.
DOCUMENTS OBTAINED BY THE
INTERCEPT ARE REVEALING THAT
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER WERE
CLOSELY COLLABORATING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IN THE FBI TO POLICE WHAT THEY
CALL IS DISINFORMATION ANYTHING
FROM WITHDRAWAL OF OUR TROOPS
FROM AFGHANISTAN TO THE ORIGINS
OF COVID.
IN FBI AGENT WAS AND DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH FACEBOOK AND
HELPED SPEARHEAD THE DECISION T
SUPPRESS THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTO
STORY IN 2020.
ONE OF THE MORE REMARKABLE
FINDINGS FROM INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALIST WHO UNCOVERED THIS I
THAT FACEBOOK AND TWITTER
CREATED SPECIAL PORTALS FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO RAPIDLY REQUEST
TAKEDOWNS OF CONTENT.
HOW DID DHS JUSTIFY ALL THIS?
THEY SAID THAT FALSE INFORMATIO
IS A SOURCE OF RADICALIZATION
AND VIOLENCE.
IN OTHER WORDS IS LICENSED TO
CENSOR THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS
.
CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER GUESS
TONIGHT.
HOW BIG OF A STORY IS THIS?
>> IT IS ENORMOUS, I THINK THE
COVER-UP THAT WE FOUND OUT FROM
THE FBI IN COLLUSION WITH BIG
TECH OVER OUR STORY, IS BIGGER
THAN THE ORIGINAL STORY OF
CORRUPTION.
NOW WE SEE THAT IT EXPANDS RIGH
ACROSS TO ALL THESE OTHER ISSUES
, PARTICULARLY COVID
VACCINES, YOU MENTIONED THAT
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN, AL
SORTS OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
AWKWARD DISASTERS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
END UP BEING FOR WHAT IS BEING
SUPPRESSED.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
TO SILENCE DISSENT, TO STOP THE
CRITICS.
I GUESS THAT'S BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T HAVE A RECORD T
RUN ON.
HE FIRED LAST WEEK, THEY DISCUS
THE PLANS FOR CENSORSHIP.
I KNOW THIS DOESN'T SURPRISE YO
COMING FROM THE NEW YORK POST.
ABSOLUTELY WAS, WE KNOW BECAUSE
HE HAS ADMITTED THAT FACEBOOK
CAME TO HIS PEOPLE JUST BEFORE
OUR STORY BROKE IN OCTOBER OF
2020 AND WARNED THEM ABOUT A
STORY TO WORK OUT FOR
INFORMATION THAT WAS JUST LIKE
OUR STORY.
THAT WAS THE SAME FBI AGENTS WH
ARE NAMED IN THIS LAWSUIT IN
MISSOURI WHICH IS EXPOSING ALL
OF THESE INTERNAL DOCUMENTS
THESE INTERNAL E-MAILS AT
TWITTER AND FACEBOOK AND FEELIN
HOW WIDESPREAD THESE CENSORSHIP
CAMPAIGN WAS.
IT WASN'T JUST OVER THE HUNTER
BIDEN LAPTOP, BUT IT TURNS OUT
IT WAS OVER THEY HAD YOUR
AGENCIES, REACHING OUT TO
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER AND
MICROSOFT, ALTHOUGH SOCIAL MEDI
COMPANIES IT SEEMS THAT THE
EXECUTIVES OF BIG TECH WERE MOR
THAN HAPPY TO ROLL OVER.
>> THEY DOCUMENTS THAT YOU WERE
REFERENCING HIS BROADER, J.P.
MORGAN ATTENDED NEARLY ALL OF
THE CYBERSECURITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETINGS ON
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION.
AGAIN, QUICKLY, THEY ARE LAYING
THE GROUNDWORK, ARE THEY NOT FO
THIS IDEA OF DEEP BANKING TO
BECOME A MORE MAINSTREAM
STRATEGY REMOVING THE ABILITY O
PEOPLE TO HOUSE AND BUILD MONEY
IN CERTAIN INSTITUTIONS FOR THI
LOOKS LIKE WHERE IT'S GOING.
>> IT IS CHILLING PARADE WE SAW
A TASTE OF THAT WITH THE
CANADIAN PROTESTS AND WE HAVE
SEEN IT HERE WITH GO FUND ME
JUST CLOSING DOWN ANYTHING TO D
WITH CONSERVATIVES.
THIS IS A TERRIFYING CCP CHINA
LIKE COLLUSION BETWEEN BIG
CORPORATE, BIG TECH, WHATEVER
YOU CALL IT IN ONE SIDE OF
POLITICS.
THIS IS WHY THEY ARE GOING
COMPLETELY NUTS ABOUT ELON MUSK
BUYING TWITTER.
FREE SPEECH IS THEIR ENEMY AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO SHUT IT D